In the movies, in real life
Crazy life ! In a musical !
In Mexico !
A chicken !
In spaaaace !
Ca faisait un moment qu'on se disait : "Eh ! Il faudrait peut-être faire un truc type Movies vs life
où on se déguise, on fait plein de trucs, où c'est trop cool !
C'est un kiff de comédien de jouer plein d'univers différents
On devait commencer la production, etc. Et il nous manquait en effet quelques sketchs
et Julien dit : "on fait Movies vs life 2?" "Mais grave ! "
Puppy ! Oh ! Vas-tu fermer ta gueule ?
On tourne sur un toit où y a pas de rebord déjà, ça fait peur !
Il fait froid. Il fait 1, voire pas de degré, y a aucun degré là !
Heureusement, le ciel est avec nous parce qu'il est uni ; là c'est un temps moche
mais c'est parfait pour un tournage. Y a pas le soleil qui vient et qui s'en va.
Et le 15 décembre, je suis revenu. Et j'ai tué tout le monde ! Toi, ta soeur...
Ahahaha!! C'est moi qui rigole !
Ahahaha ! T'es mort !
Ca c'est bien, on fera bien le même mouvement, faut retenir un truc,
c'est que tes mouvements sont hyper importants. Donc, fais bien exactement le même mouvement
avec les cagoules et tous les trucs.
Ouais, ça c'est bien, c'est bien !
Le truc que j'avais un peu oublié moi, sur Movies vs life, c'est que c'est chiant à produire en fait !
C'est trop ouf ! On se met dans la peau de pirates, de plein d'univers différents, on est comme des mômes !
Et en même temps, en production c'est horrible parce que c'est à chaque fois 1 univers, 1 maquillage différent,
des costumes différents, un lieu différent.
Là il est 12h30 - 13h, je sais pas exactement, et on bouge dans un bois pour faire un plan sur une falaise.
On est presque pas trop en retard sur cette journée improbable.
Le cri du mec qui n'a pas peur ! Aaaah ! Aah !
Je pensais qu'on allait plus galérer avec le fond vert, parce qu'il n'est pas très grand.
On est censé faire croire à un précipice.
Silence ! Ca tourne !
Aaaaaah ! Remonte moi ! Je vais crever !
Je tombe ! Mais lâche moi ! De toutes façons, tu tombes ! C'est mort ! C'est mort !
Lâche moiiiii ! Lâche ! Lâche !
Je vais faire diversion.
Tu fais diversion?
Courte paille ! Courte paille !
Non, non, pas de courte paille, ta gueule !
Très très vite, tu bouffes plein d'univers et ça va trop trop vite !
Et tu fais wow! c'est hyper riche, y a plein de choses dedans. Ca implique de se déplacer beaucoup.
Il a fallu étaler le tournage sur plusieurs jours parce que tu dois faire plein de déplacements, c'est un peu la course !
On lance un top pour qu'il y en ait un qui bouge la tête.
C'est ce que je vais faire : premier top, Bertrand tombe, ensuite c'est Vincent qui fait le deuxième top et Sarah tombe.
Bertrand d'abord. Action !
Top !
On a un guest en zombie, qui n'est pas facilement reconnaissable.
C'est un mec drôle, qui fait des chroniques courtes et vivaces.
C'est un monsieur qui travaille à la télé, avec mon sosie qui parle comme ça !
Alors, on s'en sort ?
Comme sur des roulettes ! Attention ! Hop là !
Bien joué !
Merci ! Et dis donc, est ce que tu sais comment on fait des pâtes ?
N'importe quoi !
La référence un peu pour ce sketch, c'est un peu la séquence de demande en mariage entre Orlando Bloom
et la petite blonde que j'aime pas trop...
Keyra Knightley !
Keyra Knightley ! Exactement ! Elle a beaucoup trop de consonnes dans son nom.
On est en tout 8 pirates. Il faut chorégraphier une mini-baston.
Tu recules, tu recules.
On vient se positionner comme ça, et tu viens te mettre de profil.
Donc en gros, je fais semblant, on se parle, et ensuite "comme sur des roulettes", et là je m'écarte et tu attaques
tu te prends le truc.
On s'en sort?
Comme sur des roulettes ! Hop attention !
Bien joué !
C'est intéressant de faire un vrai 2, en se foutant même de la gueule des 2,
explosons le concept, allons de plus en plus loin, avec Crazy life, avec Mexico, in space, on part totalement en live.
No gringo ! Aaah !
Si ! Ah c'est quoi ça ! Je suis désolé !
Je suis trop vieux pour ces conneries !
Vincent, ça devient notre cascadeur attitré ! C'est ouf, en plus tu les rends trop vite.
La cascade toit, elle était vraiment pas facile parce qu'il y avait des repères de ouf
C'était avec le mini-van qu'ils avaient loué pour nous transporter.
Action !
On fait James Bond, parce qu'on est des gamins.
Nickel ! On n'avait pas eu de bûche encore. Comment ridiculiser un mec en smocking en 2 secondes.
Pardon attends !